[Music]
you started a kind of a rant about the
Expendables movies you sort of went
after Swartz's the cast Swardson Egger
Stallone and those guys jean-claude Van
Damme and you got a ton of have hate
tweets I did ton of them let me just
first say I wasn't making fun of them as
much as expressing concern for their
tendons because although you can get
your muscles that big there's nothing to
really help your tendons stay so your
Samberg - what you were saying you were
saying that his action heroes you don't
buy it anymore you know cuz they
actually can't run was my point but I
don't even want to rehash that all I
wanted to say I do want to rehash the
point I was making is that in the movie
you'll never see them chase a bad guy
[Laughter]
fight you run we can't fight these I
can't chase
please do more than fight that fight you
all right I got all these mad angry like
we fly alone tweets and I thought this
is where we've come in this country that
I can understand not making fun of
minorities or homosexuals or it's not a
group that needs to be protected
yes these are multi-millionaire alpha
males ripped to the gills superhero men
yeah some people are defending yeah it's
like if I were making fun of Greek gods
I was literally making fun of the
Terminator and Rambo and people felt the
need to protect them from Dax Shepard
[Applause]
gilli yeah the bully from Parenthood who
might be a comedian who even know funny
enough to be called a comedian no but
what I'm saying is people got very very
angry and did you do you apologize that
or absolutely not yeah
[Applause]